well put your party hats on because the
five is 11 today so to kick off our
celebration we asked you our loyal
viewers to tell us what you love most
about this show
happy 11th anniversary my five from
french firecracker
greatest show on fox news i love you all
equally
[Music]
the one and only just to me
everybody
[Music]
what do i love about the five
well i'm probably not the only one who
might say this but it's so clear
i love greg
[Music]
i love judge janine i love jesse
philadelphia baby
jessica tarloff
happy 11th birthday baby you guys rock
i love roraldo's mustache i really just
want to squeeze it the one democrat
i
super like is harold ford jr dana is
always the voice of reason this is true
no matter the season jesse is
entertaining you don't know what he'll
say i'm very glad there's a seven second
delay judge janine is just like a
peppermint patty she's a
breath of fresh air
whenever i watch the five i always learn
something that i didn't already know i
love the playfulness even more between
all of you i laugh i smile
i get motivated and y'all give me so
much energy thanks for doing what you
guys do
we appreciate you and continue doing
what you're doing it's a great service
to our country and to the world oh guys
that was amazing it's like an actual
focus group um you can send that to the
advertisers
because
what a great thing to hear all those
different perspectives um it's been i
can't believe i've been on the show for
11 years yeah i can't imagine those
first shows must have been terrible
actually looking back i wish craig were
here but he's got a little thing today
so yeah i was going to say it's going
rather quick
[Laughter]
that's why it's always great to you know
come and hang out harold you're the
newest member here i think i told you
guys this is greg i mean for my kids
watching greg do the one more thing go
animals are great that's how my kids and
i got hooked on the show so thank you
guys for having me jesse i'm going to
just point out real quick before we get
your reaction we have food here from
arthur and sons this is a amazing new
restaurant it's located in chelsea they
also own serendipity 3 which i think
we've probably all been to before and
had that amazing food there yeah um they
have fame we have spicy rigatoni alla
vodka and meatballs with ricotta and we
have something else over here we have
bread garlic bread and we have a big
cake
cannolis got the coconut oil oh yes get
the cannoli jesse i don't want to say
anything i just want to eat the rigatoni
me too
right now arthur and sons thank you so
much yes
what do you think about the five well i
think i love it i'll tell you you know
what you get a chance to uh you know to
pipe off all the different topics of the
day i love it i love you all that's a
great part of it our viewers have made
it awesome one of the things i've always
been amazed by is how they remember
things that happened 11 years ago and
they can tell you exactly what it was
and who said it and why it made them
laugh or cry
no there's no tears right
why didn't greg want to be here on the
11th anniversary was he hiding something
no he's got he's he's he's actually
coming to something for me later so he
had to take this show i think i believe
because oh you know that's all that's
really that sounds very
i know as soon as i'm saying it i'm like
no that's not what i meant
everybody i promise put some food inside
we're gonna eat some i mean food here
we'll be right back hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now